[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in ryan clark here the espn
nfl analyst won a super bowl with the uh
steelers um what did you think of the
halftime show there ryan
i thought it was amazing um you like my
father uh definitely think that prince
singing purple rain and rain is the best
one
uh
you know how it is we have recency bias
you know at the time i saw that one i
didn't think it was the best purple rain
was the first um r-rated movie i got to
see uh it was the first boobs i ever got
to look at on tv when she jumped in the
waters of uh lake mona tonka but it
really wasn't that late uh you know so
that was definitely nostalgic for me and
it was amazing because he's obviously
and honestly probably the the greatest
musician a total musician that we've
ever had play
um at the super bowl but you know i was
in there last night man i think for me
you know i'm thinking you know 92
chronic you know chronic 2001 uh eight
mile um obviously i'm a huge kendrick
lamar fans and you know being able to be
there and be a part of it it was the one
i enjoyed the most
you know and so and so i think we can
all go back and forth about which one
was best man but i thought it was i
thought it was smart to to use the la
folks obviously mary j blige is you know
queen of r being hip-hop so i thought it
was a real good show all right where do
you want to start
the bengals lost because
what
well the bengals lost because of what i
think everybody always thought they
would lose lose for in the end of the
the game was offensive line uh we knew
if it got into a game where they had to
block aaron donald and you know linux
floyd also von miller that it could be
very difficult this is the team that the
tennessee titan sank nine times and so
to think that you'd be playing against
the greatest defensive player of our era
a defensive tackle and that wouldn't
affect the game at some point
i think it's crazy to believe but on the
other side of it
if aaron donald
legally pushes your quarterback inbounds
to out of bounds
don't go start a fight with a man you
can't beat up
right don't don't energize the leader of
that defense and if you look throughout
the night i feel like the cincinnati
bengals made stupid play after stupid
play that hurt their team from a penalty
standpoint and on the other side of that
and they look like the less experienced
football team toward the end of the game
they look like the team that had never
been there before which is something
that's tough because it doesn't mean
just because you're young you're going
to get back there another time
what happened with cooper cup on the
final drive
um luana rumo the defensive coordinator
of the cincinnati bengals who's
absolutely been phenomenal in the second
half of games finally made his first
mistake um if i don't have tyler higbee
on the field if i don't have odell
beckham jr on the field
i'm probably playing cooper cup the way
people play calvin johnson in the red
zone and vicing him like it's punt team
cooper cup should have been doubled on
every snap of that drive you knew he
would be the go-to guy instead they
decided to play a ton of cover three
which allowed cooper cup to manipulate
the zone coverages and make plays and
then obviously you have the logan wilson
holding uh you have the dpi
on eli apple and for the life of me i do
not know why you have eli apple
one-on-one with the best receiver in
football on the goal line i'm taking
that even if dan patrick is throwing
uh i would have completed that i mean
it's almost like
it it's like when the patriots had
single coverage on uh plexigo burst
yes ellis hobbs and you're going
you know eli's looking he goes we're
gonna win the super bowl
yeah it kind of break it breaks to mind
the kyle of murray the kylie murray
video where he sees deandre hopkins 101
and as he's throwing it he's smiling
because you knew what type of matchup
you had i'm sure that's the same way
that matthew stafford felt more likely
to get back
to the super bowl next year rams or
bengals
you know the rams have a lot of cap
issues uh so it depends on who they who
they're able to keep um
but i think you i think you'd say the
the the cincinnati bengals in the sense
of they understand what they have to fix
fix
protection add depth at the cornerback
position make sure jesse bates is still
on the team you know those are those are
the things that they have to do to make
sure this team is good again i think the
only thing that sways you from that is a
guy named patrick mahomes a guy named
josh allen a guy named justin herbert
guy named lamar jackson when you look at
the quarterbacks that are in the afc you
could probably say the bengals may end
up being the better team in 2022 but the
los angeles rams would have the easier
road um but i think the cincinnati
bengals have a great young nucleus
a team that's going to be explosive for
years to come with those skills skilled
players and an obvious fix to some of
their elves did joe burrow do anything
wrong
last night
you know
i don't think he did anything wrong
i do think
this is the first time we can say in a
moment he needed to elevate
and elevate a team
above its mean or above its up its
opponent this is the first time we
haven't seen him do it in a big moment
you know um whether it's been georgia
oklahoma clemson tennessee
kansas city las vegas we're so used to
seeing him in tight games where teams
might be better when that moment comes
stepping up in that moment and last
night he didn't get the opportunity uh
to do that and now you can also say
that's because his guards his two guards
and his center didn't protect him and he
was getting pressure into his face the
whole game but i don't feel like we give
every quarterback that out he played
well but i just don't think when he had
an opportunity to have that joe burrow
true legacy moment that he made the
plays he needed to we're talking to ryan
clark the espn nfl analyst and of course
former defensive back won a super bowl
with the steelers back i believe in 2009
matthew stafford now a hall of famer is
it that simple
um i don't know i don't know if it's
that simple but i think now the the
conversation is a lot closer
you know um
i mean i think you know that's my my
wife's alarm i think it uh all depends
um is she still sleeping
nah she's awake i'm not really sure why
it's going off right now uh you know i
think it all depends on on how you saw
matthew stafford's tenure
in um in detroit you know i think
obviously we all saw him as an elite
talent um you have all the fourth
quarter comebacks because they were down
so much um and you have the pro bowls
you have the numbers and so if one
is enough for him to get there then
maybe uh and maybe i'll say this
i don't think this makes him a first
battle hall of famer no
you know and so that maybe that's what
i'll say because so many times
when i think of hall of famers you you
almost get into like no-brainer land
right like if you walked into a room of
football players or former football
players or people who love the game of
football and you say barry sanders
everybody in that room goes yup
you know you say peyton manning yup tom
brady yup you know jonathan ogden yep
and i don't know if matthew stafford is
in that place of hall of fame for me so
sometimes it's hard to say yeah they're
guaranteed the hall of fame when you
don't know if their first ballot hall of
famer or not i call those guys the no
pause because if i say if you say hey is
matthew stafford a hall of famer and i
pause
then maybe he's not a hall of famer like
philip rivers
i might think a minute
yeah i agree but there are certain guys
where you go no pause
devin hester didn't get in is devin
hester going to get into the hall of
fame
yes okay yes
and i don't think i don't think devin
hester's problem is production
or hall of fame success i think devin
hester's problem is position
right he played he didn't necessarily
star
at a
offensive or defensive position he was a
specialist i think it's difficult for us
to see specialists as that important
and you're not going to put devin hester
over some of these other positional
players who have been waiting
you know um but nobody's going to
approach these numbers ever again ryan
with you know we've diminished the
kickoff
and yeah like that you don't even get
those opportunities these numbers are
going to stand a lifetime
yeah he's going to be he's probably
going to be the last specialist to ever
get in along with being the first
uh the game the game has changed you
know so much
and if
you were playing during devon's doing
devin hester's times you understood the
magnitude of his impact right you
understood that when you were playing
the chicago bears at that time you
gained planned more for devin hester
than you did rex grossman
right you you you remember the
indianapolis kickoff that turned into
six right away like all of those moments
are so prevalent uh in my mind
and i don't know if you're you know if
you're presenting him uh to the rest of
the hall of fame voters you have to make
sure people
understood and understand the magnitude
of his impact
did you meet anybody during super bowl
week that uh
blew you away
yeah and this is gonna sound
uh very i would guess
was it 1990s of me i met urkel
i met jalil white
i'm out to dinner um i have a podcast
called the pivot now
um obviously nfl live and so i'm out to
dinner with all of my friends a guy
walks up to me with a mask like taps my
chest shakes my hand hugs me like man i
love your show i love everything you do
on tv i'm always watching but he has the
mask on him so you know i'm just kind of
like oh thank you so you know the whole
thing you do that thank you so much such
a blessing you know we got we got our
lines you know and he takes this mask
off and i'm like it's mickey fickey
urkel you know and so and so like when
it happens and what's going on you
didn't call me merkel did you
in my head not out okay okay
not out loud i know his name is jalil i
called him jalil you know but then you
know dan orlowski stands up and marcus
spears and everybody at the table is up
because like that's our childhood
you know so for somebody like
uh jaleel white to appreciate my work
after i sat on every friday on tgif and
watched him you know i thought it was um
just a really a really cool moment and
kind of like a full circle young ryan
moment by the way orlovsky is so
obnoxious with this matthew stafford
love you know i haven't turned a tv on
yeah he's got a shirt on you got a
t-shirt says matthew freaking stafford
he thinks he won the super bowl not
staffordshire well i will tell you this
dan what i've learned about the other
dan is
you want a friend like him
right like if you want if you need
somebody to believe in udp
and never waver on their belief in you
get you a friend like dan orlowski i
already know if anybody ever walks up
today and is like ryan clark is a
terrible analyst dan will die
before he allows that person to walk off
and believe anything differently of me
you know it's crazy i give you so you
know dan was at the game last night in
matthew's box right and his suite
with the family
yes and he planned a red eye to make
sure he could be at work this morning
just in case he want like this was
this was plotted out dp this wasn't this
isn't an accident that he has the
t-shirt ready and all those things he
was not missing monday morning if
matthew stafford won the super bowl and
uh we were texted throughout the game we
have a group text and everybody's like
could you imagine
if
matthew stafford loses this super bowl
and the indianapolis coats are talking
about getting rid of carson wentz it'll
be the worst monday in daniel
ever
uh thanks for uh getting up with us i
know you had a long night and uh thank
you again uh throughout the season
joining us we always appreciate uh your
insights
yes sir you have a great one all right
that's ryan clark on the mothership espn
nfl analyst on a super bowl back with
the steelers at 09.